today we're going to talk about
eyelashes and really important
nutritional factors in relationship to
helping you grow your eyelashes or make
them thicker or longer now per eyelid
you have about 1 to 200
hair follicles and the hairs that grow
out of your eyelids go through um two
different phases one is a growth phase
and a rest phase and when people start
either losing their eyelashes or
they become small and very thin there's
a problem with one of these two phases
and there's a lot of different technical
names for these conditions that describe
them but that doesn't really tell you
what's really behind this problem i mean
if we just take a look at the basics we
have the eyelash what is an eyelash well
it's protein
what makes up protein amino acids
what makes up amino acids well we have a
combination of this biochemical reaction
occurring with certain raw material
which one really important factor would
be
trace minerals okay so you need trace
minerals to make amino acids which then
help turn into proteins which are
basically just a long chain of different
amino acids and when you're missing
certain trace minerals
devastating things can happen to your
body much like missing a trace mineral
in the soil will have devastating
effects on the plants as well as
devastating effects on the animals that
eat the plant and on top of that the
devastating effects of humans eating
animals that are deficient in certain
trace minerals now i just want to
mention a book that i'm reading which is
actually relates to this topic it's a
fascinating book this is it right here i
don't know if you can see it
soil grass and cancer
okay
now when i first found this book
sounded very very interesting
until i got to the price which was 250
dollars
so immediately i said there's no way in
hell i'm going to buy a book that's 250
despite revealing the link between human
and animal health and mineral balance in
the soil which got my attention because
i'm doing all sorts of experiments on my
phone so about an hour later
it's basically haunting me i'm thinking
why can't i find any used books that are
a lot less expensive um i mean why
aren't people getting rid of this book i
mean
maybe it's extremely valuable and no one
is wanting to resell it and it starts to
evolve to this point of like i have to
get this book i have to see what's in
this book because
um it must be good if it's that
expensive or i would i would see some
negative reviews i haven't seen any
negative reviews only amazing reviews
now of course it's a bit technical for
the average person but
it's a fascinating study on the
relationship between
missing trace minerals in the soil
and how that affects the plant and the
animals and humans
because the foundation of our health
actually starts in the soil if there's
something missing in the soil which
there is
how can you create food and animals that
feed us that
turn into health you can't and these
little trace minerals are vitally
important because
it's at the heart of enzymes it's at the
heart of making vitamins like b12 and
it's at the heart of making antioxidants
and even phytonutrients
all right so let me get back on topic
here because i'm getting a little
distracted
so if you investigate and look up the
mechanism
of why someone would lose their
eyelashes it comes down to a
deficiency
of a very specific type of
prostaglandin now don't get too hung up
on this word prostaglandin
prostaglandin is just a signaling
molecule it's kind of like a hormone
it's a
a message that travels to the body that
tells the body to do certain things and
if you're deficient in a certain
prostaglandin you can have all sorts of
uh problems with growing hair
inflammation and yet if there's other
prostaglandins that you have too much
that can relate to things like headaches
for example when you take an aspirin
what you're doing is you're blocking
certain types of prostaglandins and
that's why aspirin works for headaches
but in summary some of the medications
that they use involved in growing
eyelashes have to do with
enhancing
this deficiency of this specific
prostaglandin called prostaglandin f2
alpha if you really wanted to know we're
just going to call this pgf2 alpha and
that way we can sound a little bit
smarter so there's actually just two
things you need to know about
increasing this
deficiency of this prostaglandin one is
an acid
called rescinolic acid that acid can
help correct that deficiency and help
someone regrow their eyelashes not just
help grow it but can it can actually
thicken the eyelashes and then help the
texture to make them
have the right oil
consistency and number two
zinc and that is the trace mineral that
i'm leading up to when you're a zinc
deficient
you can't make that
prostaglandin now remember i talked
about trace minerals making all sorts of
things like enzymes and phytonutrients
well they also make this signaling
molecule called prostaglandin and
without zinc you can't make it so this
is why zinc is really important in
your nails your skin your hair
your immune system uh making
testosterone it's involved in literally
like a hundred different biochemical
reactions at least and so there's been
quite a few reports and people taking
zinc and helping
regrow their hair and specifically the
eyelashes now if you're going to get a
zinc supplement i would highly recommend
you get a quality
zinc supplement in a blend of all the
trace minerals and to be totally
transparent i have a zinc product and a
blend of all the trace minerals that i
sell i'm not even telling you to get
that product it's actually more
important to find out why you're
deficient in zinc in the first place
like looking at your diet so zinc is
involved in regrowing the eyelashes and
also this resinoic acid which by the way
is in castor oil now castor oil is a
laxative
it's a preservative it is something that
helps women induce labor when they're
about to deliver it's used as a skin
moisturizer it's also used as an anti
dandruff
remedy but a lot of women use it to help
regrow their eyelashes and personally if
you're going to get castor oil
just make sure it's organic and it's a
cold processed or unrefined as long as
it's that you don't have to get a very
very expensive castor oil because a lot
of the castor oil really comes from the
same place
because some people actually sell in
these very tiny bottles
where it's
you know you can get the same material
in a much larger bottle at a fraction of
the cost so the two best things for the
eyelashes are number one zinc and castor
oil i would put castor oil topically and
take zinc internally because that way
you're working on something from the
inside out now there's a really
interesting study done on mice where
they evaluated
feeding mice aspirin because aspirin
blocks those prostaglandins right and
this is what they found they found that
when they did that they created the
exact same effect as a zinc deficiency
because they looked at the symptoms of a
zinc deficiency and a prostaglandin
deficiency and are both the same and the
lesson or take away from this video
is to
understand
what these
symptoms are what these like little red
light indicators are
and instead of camouflaging a hole in
the bucket find out what the deeper
underlying root cause is
instead of just patching a hole and so
this leads me to the next video that you
really should watch
as in what are some of the causes of a
zinc deficiency and how can you correct
it right here check it out